bella più dilaniata misure sono quello
che fai video svolga ai fianchi gente la
mia vecchio nome quello adesso giochiamo
fa ma le cose serie perché oltre ad uno
via marco demonio ma perché guarda la
partenza in cui mi fanno e sono partito
benissimo sono piste hanno fatto cadere
ottimo era un po che non tocco sulla
play prima cosa che faccio uno che
arriva addosso mi fa cadere fantastico
attenzione buono solo a chi caduto v6
giocato qua ti prego passa non è vero
mai nella vita o ragazzino è veramente
difficile passare in questo punto quale
mi piace tra yard harlow all'inizio
perché prima o poi porco demonio da di
nove ragazzi non lo farò le più schietta
scherzavo non lo farò mai più
non ti prego vinci mi sento troppo i com
allora è la prima volta che faccio una
cacata della prima volta paymat manders
6 deco buttato su diego ha puntato più
primaria già partiti i primi quindi è un
ottimo vantaggio insisto perché è
perfetto io che parlo magari sto zitto
la prossima volta va bene sto dicendo
che è un vantaggio perché se sei primo è
veramente riesce a passare davanti agli
altri proprio perché si sa è fatta forza
perché se sei primo riesce a saltare su
una piattaforma poi sulle altre senza
ostacoli perché sono gli avversari gli
ostacoli però 6 prima ecco come non è
capito un lato ma dovevi bollare ha
bollato ti faccio ok perfetto agli di
quanta gente mentale male ogni volta la
mappa del cuore che ce l'ha fatta limite
o per lavorava ravara varava adesso c'è
lo skip del martello che tutti stanno
usando il maine tata nano o da ma fa
niente non lo usiamo perché
noi vogliamo vincere altre parti non
c'era niente legale primi madonna sta
vomitando spinge l'importante ragazzi
arrivare primi nelle mappe se si arriva
primi anche nella prima sfida perché
almeno puoi provare alla parità perfetta
però non lo è in questo caso basta basta
cadere basta cadere basta cadere abdulla
tamina mano stavo dicendo che la sindaco
gatto non sono effettivamente perché un
po più grossa nelle altre non so se ti
aiuta poi una mia se ti penalizza una
mia impressione ragazza di però mi
sembra di andare molto più liscio con
questa ragazzi la più brutta partita su
slide klein da quando il gioco a sto
gioco vi giuro non so che mai preso oggi
è importante arrivare perché tenebre 14
13 la vera potrebbe farci fare la finale
che ovviamente sarebbe potrebbe anche se
l'ex ago in realtà non so se mi devo
pagare addosso cosa attenzione no basta
col mouse dei maledizione di prima
mentre nella prima fila si è appena ce
la possa fare per vincere mi ha messo
nella prima fila quindi me la gioco dei
primi cinque attenzione full monty
baculo se ti mette nelle ultime file 6
sfigato e non è colpa tua
ovvero che avesse una prima fila forse
il gesù mi ha graziato proviamoci dai
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye tutto a posto ma
devo la destra ragazzi con demonio
non è vero ho sbagliato perche non e
vero sono ancora primo non so come sia
possibile perché ho sbagliato se sbagli
una volta che finisce col mondo invece
palazzo primo veloce addio di nicchia
eccolo non mi ha preso c'era tavolo
presa da sotto ho fatto tipo sono
attaccato con i denti ma allora come
abbiamo detto prima dove la meritavo
però lo sai 30 schifo che ho fatto però
sul monte l'ho giocata bene peccato che
come una palla in faccia come dico
sempre stavolta è andata di culo a me
perché fall montain e se ti mette primo
arrivi se non arrivi solo se gli altri
sbagliano quindi non è meritocratica
dov'è il muro qua a sinistra cioè la mia
destra adesso è quello giusto ok non è
meritocratica che se parti ultimo non
può davvero che non sbagliano quelli
davanti non puoi vincere quindi non mi
tasso di dà soddisfazione vincere perché
se per la partita vinta ma vincere in
extra con me la da sei volte tanto il
job showdown
allora c'era una porta che non andava
una una job placement quello dove fare
perché era partito malissimo perché una
sfiga tremenda
be nice ragazzi più parti a da buttare
ormai una volta una delle mie preferite
adesso da buttare veramente non lo parti
non lo parti non le parti non dalle
parti non lo parti non parti non bloc
party
mamma mia
va bene jean clair che tanto non faccio
mai gianfreda ma credo che sia la mappa
con meno radio riuscita possibile perché
non esce mai ti prego mi sono saltato
non è italiano ragazzi la facciamo
passare e la tensione l'attenzione ho
sbagliato a partire perché se tu rimani
attaccato su cosa non ti alzi il mio
ragazzo quindi non vi alzate più quindi
è un problema quello io faccio prima a
rimanere fermo ad aspettare quando
arrivai mi muovo solo se il sito
grappone tipo adesso porca vacca come ho
fatto bene
la qashqai gente è arrivato lo stesso
sesso non potevo neanche a disp non
possiamo distrarmi perché mi distraevo
era finita
non mi sono distratto e mi arrivato un
saab lo ha detto il tuo nome caro però
welcome in de giacomo grazie mille per
esserti abbonato nel momento più
sbagliato la mia vita però grazie
ho anche già anche jean showdown va bene
ma se non sia quel monte va bene va bene
signori non faccio il trucco né un'altra
volta non voglio trarre altare perché ho
già vinto una partita e il genere in
hexagon le vinco sempre al 95 per cento
non è questa cagata con il minimo calo o
passa in mezzo il glitch del passare in
mezzo sicuro non la vinco però siccome
non vintage a una avrei player da se non
avesse vinto la prima però se ho vinto
la prima voglia fare lui di fila provava
la normale ok non mi butto giù con
trucco nuovo con le bologna porco parco
aveva accettato se all'inizio dial aiuto
e aiuto perché corni tua madre brutta
perché ti hanno accudito male da piccolo
non devi correre santo i disabili alcune
di prendermi male
partenza pessima pessima per un ex con
permesso ma infatti dopo non debba donna
come ti ho perso di miche cani ti prego
guarda che sta camminando sul niente
guarda non ve ricorderei santo iddio non
correte in hexagon non correte donna non
si corre in ex ago però io io sabato
sulle piattaforma che non ci sono cadeau
l'altro no mi correva dietro porco
demonio come questa regola vale per gli
altri non per me maggio c'è un buco nel
metodo dica che sta succedendo 18
ragazzi questa mattina non mi piace
stampa perché so che non so cosa stia
succedendo di tutto
stanno facendo un buon lavoro cina è al
centro orribile per cascato un cavallo
addosso fare i genitori a 20 c
meglio che ci sbalzo qualche stanza c'è
un amministratore della piattaforma ti
fa niente lo spazio sono i gialli di
sotto
no mi sta togliendo la prego bastati due
solo e vabbè dai cadiamo a non facesse
faccio rischio buonissimo ed urlato ok
ok buonissima caduto cavallo man 2
no no no
e caduto lui è caduto lui è capo di
mercato con uno dietro non c'entra
niente ma cristo va bene va bene è
giusto è giusto avevamo vinto va bene un
giocatore forte e sono stato qua schede
anche nella chat
mi piace al vino e noi come sempre
vediamo allora
[Musica]